[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 a
nivel mundial el virus kobe 19 les costó
a las mujeres a más de 800 mil millones
de dólares en ingresos perdidos en un
año un valor equivalente al pib
combinado de más de 98 naciones a
propósito del día del trabajo que se
conmemora cada año del primero de mayo
la ong oxfam publicó datos que dan
cuenta de cómo las mujeres se padecimos
más por trabajos de ingresos en lo que
va desde que fue declarada la pandemia
además de estar ya sobre representadas
en sectores precarios y mal remunerados
la crisis empeoró las condiciones
las consecuencias económicas de la
pandemia impactan con más fuerza en las
mujeres somos las que más ocupamos
puestos de trabajo en condiciones
precarias e inseguras y con mayor riesgo
de desempleo aparte de eso llegamos a la
casa de suplir tareas de cuidado lo que
permite a otros producir en las
economías siendo las mayores aportantes
recibimos muy poco veamos
a nivel mundial las mujeres perdieron
más de 64 millones de puestos de trabajo
en 2020 un equivalente al 5 por ciento
en comparación con la pérdida del 3 9%
para los hombres aumentó la
precarización para un grupo poblacional
que ya estaba desproporcionadamente
representado en sectores que ofrecen
salarios bajos pocos beneficios y menos
seguridad y es que a nivel mundial hay
más mujeres en puestos de comercio
minorista de turismo y de servicios
alimentarios que no sólo eran mal pagos
para empezar sino que fueron los más
afectados por la pandemia en el sur de
asia áfrica subsahariana y américa
latina' la mayoría de las mujeres
trabajan en empleos informales en otros
casos constituyen aproximadamente el 70%
de la fuerza laboral de la salud y la
asistencia social en el mundo la
directora ejecutiva de oxfam
internacional gabriela bacher criticó
que en una crisis en aumento los
gobiernos no hicieron nada al respecto
en lugar de corregir ese error los
gobiernos trataron los trabajos de las
mujeres como prescindibles lo que ha
tenido un costo de al menos 800 mil
millones de salarios perdidos para
quienes tienen un empleo formal y esa es
una cifra conservadora
esa estimación ni siquiera incluye los
salarios perdidos por los millones de
mujeres que trabajan en la economía
informal trabajadoras domésticas
vendedoras de mercado y trabajadoras de
la confección que han sido enviadas a
casa o cuyas horas y salarios se han
reducido drásticamente la distribución
de la riqueza no ayuda
mientras las mujeres perdían empleos u
horas de trabajo grandes empresas
prosperaban amazon por ejemplo ganó 700
mil millones en 2020 frente a los 800
mil millones en ingresos perdidos por
las trabajadoras las pérdidas en los
hogares también son equiparables con los
721 mil 500 millones que el gobierno de
eeuu gastó en 2020 en el presupuesto de
defensa más grande del mundo conclusión
si hay dinero pero no llega a las manos
que más lo necesitan en todo el mundo
las mujeres tienen más probabilidades
que los hombres de abandonar la fuerza
laboral forzosamente o de reducir sus
horas de trabajo en gran parte debido a
las responsabilidades del cuidado que
además aumentaron en pandemia
incluso antes del virus las mujeres y
las niñas realizaban cada día 12 mil
quinientos millones de horas de trabajo
de cuidado no remunerado una
contribución a la economía mundial de al
menos 10 a 8 billones de dólares al año
de modo que las mujeres son las que más
contribuyen a la economía pero son las
que menos reciben a cambio como
consecuencia se espera que 47 millones
de mujeres en todo el mundo caigan en la
pobreza extrema viviendo con menos de
1,9 dólares al día en 2021 el cob y 19
fue un golpe contundente contra las
mujeres sino es que decir vamos a
conversar de este tema y con nosotros
esta vía skype desde bolivia de veronica
paz ella es coordinadora de
investigación e integrante de la mesa de
cuidados de la ong oxfam verónica
bienvenida a ellas hoy gracias por su
tiempo y me llama la atención que su
organización no compare la pérdida de
ingresos de las mujeres con las
ganancias de grandes compañías claro no
pienso que amazon tenga que regalarle de
sus ganancias a nadie pero hasta qué
punto las empresas que prosperaron
deberían
haber dado un paso adelante para apoyar
a los que sufren y de paso hacer algo
por la igualdad de género
buenos días un saludo cordial desde la
paz una de las uno de los temas
pendientes de las consecuencias de esta
crisis es precisamente ver que los
impactos han sido desiguales no todos
nos hemos visto afectados en la misma
medida y existen desigualdades muy
profundas que se han se han acelerado ha
acentuado las brechas entre hombres y
mujeres las derechas entre ricos y
pobres las brechas entre la población
que sí tiene un acceso y la posibilidad
de trabajar desde casa y los que no una
de las de las consecuencias más graves y
jon de esta pandemia es que se ha puesto
de nuevo en la mesa de discusión la
necesidad de que las políticas públicas
atiendan las brechas de género no
solamente en el mundo del trabajo
amanerado sino en la interacción y la
intersección con el mundo del trabajo no
remunerado
bueno y entonces según ese cambio de
políticas que es lo que nos falta porque
el dinero no les llega a las manos que
más lo necesitan
existen dos maneras de analizar este
impacto a la crisis es importante ver
que en américa latina en el mundo en
general la crisis golpea en una
situación ya previa de desigualdades muy
profundas es necesario resolver aspectos
estructurales la crisis nos ha mostrado
que la organización el trabajo de la
vida cotidiana y la gestión misma de la
vida cotidiana se ha trasladado a los
hogares millones de niños fuera de la
escuela millones de centros de atención
a la primera infancia cerrados y eso
implica que los esfuerzos que los
estados vienen haciendo aún no son
suficientes para ser sostenibles
esta idea de corresponsabilidad de los
cuidados entre el estado la sociedad y
las familias ese es uno de los campos
donde en américa latina debemos seguir
trabajando otro campo fundamental es el
tema de la de la redistribución de las
horas de trabajo de cuidado doméstico
dentro de los hogares es decir romper
con esta tradición muy fuerte de la
división sexual del trabajo que asignada
a la mujer en rol del cuidado y al
hombre
erbol
de de ser proveedor económico del hogar
existe entonces la posibilidad de
cambiar estas esas formas de
organización de la sociedad y estamos
todos convocados a poner algún tipo de
esfuerzo en este las empresas en
términos de la red de las horas por
ejemplo de baja de maternidad y
paternidad iguales que corten la
discriminación de la mujer por ejemplo
en el momento del ingreso al mercado
laboral los estados haciendo más
esfuerzos y poniendo más recursos en que
los servicios de cuidados sean realmente
de calidad y lleguen a las personas más
vulnerables y las familias generando una
mayor distribución de las tareas de
cuidado entre hombres y mujeres de
distintas edades al interior del hogar
mira veronica lo hemos dicho mucho en
este programa durante todo este año de
pandemia el cierre de la brecha de
género global aumentó en una generación
en aumento de 99.5 años a 135 6 años
debido a los resultados negativos para
las mujeres en el 2020 más de 100 años
necesitamos para que seamos tratadas con
la igualdad que necesitamos y que
merecemos qué hacemos
es muy importante también darse cuenta
que el retorno a la normalidad y la
acción también está siendo desigual no
solamente en américa latina se han
perdido más empleos femeninos y hay una
mayor y un mayor golpe en términos de
sus condiciones laborales sino que
también el retorno y la recuperación al
trabajo está haciendo mucho más difícil
para las mujeres esto quiere decir que
ya no podemos seguir normalizando la
situación de las mujeres que
tradicionalmente están empleadas como en
la o en la categoría de económicamente
inactivas como si este trabajo no
significara un esfuerzo y un valor
económico es la población que en muchos
casos se dedican al trabajo doméstico ya
cuidado que aquí en combinarlas con
políticas más tradicionales de empleo y
políticas de protección social que nos
ayuden a salir de la pandemia si no
resolvemos al mismo tiempo los factores
estructurales que vienen ampliando estas
brechas
pero además resolviendo también los
temas que la emergencia nos está de
alguna manera
y fomentando es importante que bien
miremos en varias opciones estructurales
en todos los países combinando como
decía la responsabilidad de los actores
que estamos llamados a proveer el
bienestar social en la sociedad es bueno
y otro tema que quería conversar con
ustedes es que aquí la dificultad es que
una mujer que dejó de percibir ingresos
es equivalente a una familia toda una
red de personas que se quedaron sin
comida sin servicios públicos sin techo
para vivir
pareciera que los gobiernos no entienden
eso porque al final la pobreza también
le cuesta al gobierno a la gente que no
puede producir que no puede estar
tranquilo que gasta más para el gobierno
dentro de los sistemas de salud donde
están las ayudas entonces para las
mujeres que le están poniendo el pecho a
la pandemia y detrás de ellos están sus
hijos sus esposos sus padres y bueno
todas sus redes familiares
hay una necesidad de que los estados se
empiecen a redirigir los recursos que
tienen para la financiamiento sus
políticas públicas esto implica que se
empieza a pensar en políticas
tributarias progresivas y esto tiene una
clara salida por ejemplo en impuestos a
la riqueza es decir que quienes tienen
más paguen más que se eliminen todas
aquellas medidas tributarias que de
alguna manera están recayendo sobre todo
a los hogares más pobres por ejemplo el
iba la gente en mayor en mayor
proporción en los ingresos de las
personas más pobres que se implementen
programas y políticas públicas que
rompan con esta división sexual del
trabajo y con este enfoque familista y
me refiero por ejemplo a toda una serie
de políticas de transferencias
monetarias o de programas que siguen
legitimando la responsabilidad de la
mujer en el cuidado es necesario romper
eso y demostrar que todos somos
corresponsables existe una necesidad de
un cambio de visión de las políticas
públicas transitar de visiones am y
listas hacia asia visiones de
corresponsabilidad del cuidado
una necesidad de que los recursos
lleguen a los más pobres y una necesidad
de que la captación de los ingresos
disponibles de los estados se recaude de
manera ofrecida pues mire veronica
muchísimas gracias a usted puede
llevarnos a través de este reporte que
publica oxfam y hay que decirlo la
desigualdad la sufre usted la sufro yo y
la sufrimos sobre todas las mujeres la
diferencia es que muchas no tienen el
privilegio ni la posibilidad de tener
acceso a empleos más ahora en pandemia
siga con nosotros en france 24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]